thank you very much and thank you to
everybody for coming I'm quite excited
to dive into a topic that right now is
quite popular but tackle it from a very
very practical perspective so as
mentioned I am currently the chief
scientist at the Institute for ethical
AI there we focus primarily on
developing standards industry standards
and open source work that ensures the
responsible development of the systems
at scale and my day-to-day role is as
director of machine learning engineering
at Selden technologies which is an open
source machine learning company that
provides a framework that you that
allows you to host your models in
kubernetes so for model management
monitoring serving and some of the
examples that we're going to be diving
on will actually leverage some of this
tools the examples are all open source
so you can actually jump in and try it
the gate repo for this is on github.com
slash ethical ml it's the first one that
you'll see listed explain ability and
bias and there you can find the jupiter
notebook and everything i'm by the way
the presentation is all at jupiter
notebook so let's let's pray to the demo
gods that everything works all right so
today I'm going to be covering a
hands-on example I am going to assume
that we have started a a startup a tech
startup called hype ml and we're going
to be tasked with the project of
automating a loan approval process for
an insurance company then we're going to
dive into terminology and why it's not
just about removing buyers and then
we're gonna cover the three key steps
that are involved in this in this
explain ability and bias analysis piece
and of course there are there are two
four steps because that's all right so
so hypermile a new project has come in
you know an insurance company has a
process where domain experts approve or
reject loan applications based on a set
of rules they receive over 1 million
applications and they want to automate
that and you know business wants it
yesterday and not only that but you know
they heard that they're come
predatory is using this machine learning
thing and they want all of it so the
team you know this imaginary team had a
look
so what's out there find a few tutorials
and so that data science basically boils
down into you know these two basically
abstracted processes first one is
developing the model the second one is
you know using it in production the
first part you know it includes cleaning
your data defining some features
selecting a model with high parameters
you know defining a score and then rinse
and repeat until you're happy once the
model reaches an accuracy that you're
happy with you persist that and you put
it in production make it available for
business consumption and new unseen data
comes in easy so they basically saw that
the tutorials that they were looking at
required data they went back to business
they asked for some data and business
came back with an excel sheet of 25 rows
so the team push back they were like
well we can't do anything so they got a
dataset of 8,000 rows and so it begun
the hypermile journey towards greatness
so when they started they saw that their
data set consisted of you know a tabular
data set with things like you know
working class age and then whether the
loan is approved or rejected
they basically you know followed best
practices so they split their data set
into a training data set and a testing
data set and then they just took a
neural network that they found online
hundred neurons softmax or it turns
probabilities and they just train the
model and lo and behold you know it's
pretty good learning curve yes so how
much did we get 98% accuracy cool so
first try Friday evening 98% accuracy
what better time to push the prod so who
here who here thinks that we need we
should push the prod any Cowboys in the
room yes so we push the prod we push the
prod and a few weeks go by and what what
happens you know BuzzFeed news hypermile
deploys racist sexist AI and and the
team is like well we followed all the
tutorials
you know we stacked more layers what
will happen there and the team said okay
let's diagnose it so business gathered
110 of the applications that went
through the production and you know
label that
nearly with through the domain experts
so you know now we have a new data set
there you know 110 rows and then our 13
features and then we actually try to
calculate the accuracy with that Oh what
is that 50 54 percent accuracy how did
that happen our training data set told
us is 98% we've never seen you know our
training data set in a production data
set different so when we actually see
how the model is behaving with you know
this confusion matrix which will dive
into later we see that the you know
actual positives and predictive
positives are zero so well our model is
just basically saying oh you applied for
a loan reject any loan reject so our law
we basically trained a very good model
that is great at rejecting everything so
you know that could actually be a very
very good performance depending on what
the production dataset is and when we
see the the ROC curve this tells you how
much better you're doing than randomness
and it says that we might as well just
deploy a function that says if R and dot
random you know is greater than 0.5
returned 1 l0 so you know we're doing
exactly like randomness which is I think
you know you need to put effort to be to
get that bad and basically when we
actually see our distribution of our
training deck data we see that the
number of rejected loans that we used to
train were much bigger primarily because
you know the number of applications that
may have gone through the system where
more than rejected ones on the approved
ones whereas in production now there
were some loans that you know are
expected to be approved which you know
we're all just rejected so that just you
know gave a very high-level introduction
into the concept of you know on the side
bias and then a taste of why explain
ability is important the reason why this
has become a more popular topic is
primarily because there has been a lot
of high level high profile incidents
with some tech companies where there has
been this you know blatant you know
sexist or racist models that they have
deployed but you know ultimately a lot
of the challenges that arise with this
is because of potential lags of testing
or best practices or touch points of
domain expertise which we're going to
dive in
the interesting thing here is that
organizations have been taking a step
back from using machine learning and
production primarily because not the
risks but the unknown risks so they just
don't know what potential challenges
might arise if they put something in
production and that is the objective of
standardizing and bringing best
practices together to be able to tackle
this and have those risks up front now
the challenge has to go beyond just the
algorithms and what this means is that
the large ethical decisions should not
just fall on the shoulders of a single
data scientist right a lot of the times
you see a job description for a machine
learning engineer role that requires the
person to have you know a PhD ten years
of DevOps experience you know maybe
three years of McKinsey consulting
experience you know and then for the
salary of an intern right which you know
realistically and it's funny because
that's true right like there's a lot of
applications that do that the reason why
is because we now need to understand
what are their expertise that are
required in the sub areas of machine
learning given that there is an
intersection of roles we have DevOps
software engineers and data scientists
you require best practices from all of
this to manage those top types of system
in production at scale and similarly
there's already ambiguous role of
machine learning Engineering intersects
with industry domain expertise policy
makers which is the core they call
towards you know standardizing these
best practices and more than anything is
just emphasizing that is not just the
data scientist or the software engineers
responsibility it has to be the delivery
team including the the product owner
project manager all the way to
understanding what is the accountability
that goes upstream and the answer is not
just about removing bias because any
non-trivial decision ie with one more
than one option holds a bias
you know without exceptions the whole
purpose of machine learning is to
discriminate towards the you know
correct or at least the best possible
approximation right so what we want to
do is to try to remove undesired biases
and that is what you know starts
becoming hard because even societal bias
in itself carries an inherent bias right
what some people may think racist in one
location in another one it may be
different
and it's also geographically dependent
you know some of the you know potential
considerations that we may have here may
be different somewhere in in Asia and
East somewhere else in the world so it's
just really hard right so first thing is
just to understand the complexity of
this and then take a bottom up and on
top bottom step and now let's actually
look what on the thyroid virus looks
like the way that we actually put it in
conceptual terms is in two pieces
statistical bias which is the error
carried out once you start the project
and a priori bias which is basically the
errors that you know are introduced even
before you start the project so for
statistical bias these are errors in
project decisions these are sub optimal
choices of accuracy metrics or cost
functions of optimal machine learning
models chosen for the task in a lack of
infrastructure or metric required to
monitor the performance in production
right the lifecycle lifecycle of a model
actually begins when it's actually
deployed perhaps lack of human in the
loop where necessary or not using all
the resources at your disposal from the
you know a priori bias so it's bias
introduced through societal scope
divergence this is potentially
suboptimal business objectives lack of
understanding of the project incomplete
resources like not enough data or time
or domain experts incorrectly label data
because the person made a mistake or
because the person thought it was
correct but it wasn't correct for the
tasks that it was being used for lack of
relevant skill set etc etc so there's
quite a long list and in all of this
explained ability does become key
because you need that to understand
whether you even have some error between
where you should be and where you are
also explained ability is important
because now it's being enforced from a
regulatory perspective so GDP R for
example demands for the right to explain
ability you know I don't know what that
means people don't know what it means
they don't know what it means
but we need to find out right for
accountability matters you know if
somebody requests that there needs to be
an understanding of you know based on
the critical nature of a project how
much explained ability should be
necessary and what are the techniques
that you can use for that to be the case
right and the reason why this
challenging is because explain ability
doesn't mean in
Britt ability right the the fact that
you have techniques to interpret models
doesn't mean that you understand what
that means right you can dive in and see
the interactions of the neurons of your
of your network but that doesn't mean
that you understand how it operates and
the reason what the way that we that I
normally put this into sort of like
intuitive terms when you ask a domain
expert how they came to that conclusion
they don't tell you what are the neurons
that fired in their brain they tell you
a justifiable explanation justifiable
being something extremely ambiguous
right that needs to be defined for the
task and the critical nature of that
other task and how that looks in
practice you know remember our workflow
of the data science workflow the way
that we introduce it is with three steps
this is data analysis model evaluation
and production monitoring so in this
talk we're going to be diving into each
of these areas one thing to bear in mind
though is that there is a trade-off with
explained ability a lot of times you
have to you know when introducing
explain ability whether it is like
choosing simpler models or whether it is
like using other techniques you know it
may cause into a reduce accuracy right
but often it's not just a review Secura
see you may be able to keep that same
level of accuracy but there would be
extra work right it is more red tape
that you need to introduce there may be
more and more a human in the loop
that you need to have so that would
change the way that you do it but if we
if we expect this an enterprise level
software
why wouldn't we expect this an
enterprise level data science so it is
ultimately a trade of that we need to
understand and use
so now let's dive into the practical you
know use care of these three steps the
first one is data analysis we're going
to be you know diving into data
imbalances I'm sampling down sampling
correlations trade training and test set
etc and we're going to be using the this
library open source library that focuses
on data analysis techniques
it's called Xai so the link is actually
down there so you can actually access if
you go online for the presentation but
what we have now is we have a new data
set that is being collected and manually
extracted so it's much more balanced
where
going to be using this to train a new
model and basically we're gonna be using
it to assess the imbalances within so
what this library allows us to do is to
actually ask questions like for our
dataset and the feature gender in this
case what are the number of examples
that we have for each right and in this
case then you're able to you know as the
same questions that you would have do I
have enough examples for loans right
approved loans and rejected loans you
can actually get a deeper dive into well
I want the breakdown of gender with
approved rejected loans right so even if
you were to actually make your data set
balanced in this level you know you
would still see that there is an
imbalance for example in this case of
the number of loans that have been
approved for female right so in that
sense it requires you to do a deep dive
but the one emphasis is that the
objective of this is not to make sure
everything is completely balanced right
because what does that even mean you
know it requires you to make sure that
you understand what is your actual
production data set going to look like
your production distribution going to
look like and then make sure that your
training is as close as possible of
course there is you know a a piece that
you need to also be conscious in the
longer term what are the implications of
the model that you deploy whether it may
reinforce an existing societal bias but
you know for now it's just how do we
take the first steps and start
understanding what are the best
practices on in this case data analysis
you know you can actually do also you
know analysis on numerical data sets in
this case we're assessing age and you
know of course you have you know less
number of examples if your data set
requires then you may have to actually
get more up sampling down sampling so it
follows the same pattern but now what
you can do is you want to say I want to
actually observe our data set so that
for all of the sub classes that are
lower than a certain threshold I just
want to do a simple sort of like random
copy of those of those data points and
this is a common approach of up sampling
in you know data science you can also do
it on sample down sample 2.5 for example
and then what that does is just
basically anything above the threshold
pulls it down
same the next is uncle relations you
know you need to make sure that if you
want to for example remove a protected
feature from your data set because
perhaps you may not want your model to
include it maybe like in your actual
end-to-end process that you're
automating that is also you know a no-go
to use those features when with when
dealing with this you also need to be
aware of what are the you know up front
correlations of the features you know
this is even before you actually assess
the the plots once you train your model
but what you're seeing here is basically
a dendogram using experiment are
correlate a correlation in in the x-axis
and then you know as close as it gets
you know you you would have more
correlated features and then you can see
like you know loan education number are
heavily correlated then you will have
you know ethnicity and native country
which that one is you know an obvious
one then the next thing is on actual
training and test sets so it actually
builds upon what we've seen this class
imbalance and up sampling down sampling
well what you're doing here is the usual
thing that you normally follow for
splitting your data set from training
and test what you're doing here is
you're you're doing that for your test
dataset so you wanna you're saying I
want a test dataset that gives me this
equal number of classes sorry this equal
number of examples for this sub class
breakdown so in this case you're saying
I want a minimum per group of 300 and a
maximum per group of 300 for our data
set with the sort of like feature of
gender but you can also use age or any
of the audio of the other ones and then
here then you would be able to have an
assessment of the performance of your
models using a dataset and in this case
it's balanced but again it's not about
making everything balanced because you
know that may not even actually help you
get better performance it's about you
know making sure that you have the best
represents represent ability of your
tests test dataset and what your
production dataset and your training
dataset and then of course you know
there are many many other tools that you
can jump to we actually
in a list of production machine learning
libraries in this case is for
visualization please try the more or not
all but tries to try a few you know also
a shout-out to the xkcd style plots they
look great in presentations right so
jumping into the second part model
evaluation so say we've done an analysis
of this data set again you know you may
jump from one to the other ones you find
insights but now we go into with trainer
model we want to actually do assessment
within the model the things that we're
going to cover is standard model
valuation metrics global versus local
model explanation techniques black box
versus white box it's mining some
techniques and other libraries available
for this example we're going to be using
this open source library called alibi so
it's one that our data science team put
together and a shout-out to Yanis who's
gonna be doing a lightning talk on it
later today but this focus is primarily
on black box models model explanations
so where you actually don't dive into
the internals and for this you know I
mentioned the white box versus black box
the way that there's a fairy shades
again you know our data science team put
together a very clear overview this is
basically the difference between when
you interact with a model as a black box
just the inputs and outputs try to
reverse engineer and understand how it
how the internals may behave and white
box is when you may have for example in
a random forest you you actually may
dive into all of the decision trees that
are internally within the weights and
use that as leveraging it to explain how
the model itself may work for this
specific case we're gonna focus on black
box models there's also the approach of
local versus global so globally
basically here tries to explain the
entire model itself whereas local it
explains a single prediction and for
this one we're actually going to be
showing an example for both for standard
model evaluation matrix so what we're
gonna do first is we're actually gonna
just train a new model with those
metrics that we've actually created
sorry not the meters that we created
with the data set that we now have and
we've now rebalanced so now our learning
curve looks
you know much more reasonable didn't
just shoot up to 98% on the first epoch
and we can first start with just the
confusion matrix you know most of you
guys may be familiar this looks much
more reasonable you know we now see that
the actual positive and they predict it
positive you know as are much more
balanced and with this sort of sort of
visualizations you can ask questions
such as what should I focus more on you
know what what is a bigger impact in our
system a false positive or a false
negative right you know which one should
I try to optimize for you know how can I
visualize the the global performance of
my model you know again we saw the ROC
plot before now we see that we perform
much better than randomness which is
always good
but not only that but one of the
interesting things with this is that we
can actually see things like ROC plots
on a pear sort of like subclass basis so
in this case we can ask questions of how
does our model perform in terms of just
our you know true positive rate false
positive rate in terms of male and
female breakdowns for the data set we
can also do for you know things like
ethnicity for things like you know these
are protected features that may not go
into your training but you could still
use them for evaluation of your model
similar for metrics here we are able to
see things that go beyond accuracy so at
the beginning of the presentation we
just saw accuracy but if we had seen
this we would have seen that you know at
least precision and wrinkle would have
been all the way in the floor and here
we can see all the things like you know
area under the curve f1 score but again
what is cool about this is that we can
see the breakdown of our metrics on a
per sub class level right and what you
can then ask questions for is just how
it is performing and based on our use
case should it you know what would be a
reasonable you know divergence between
all of our sort of like subclasses of
course then this then then starts you
know really opening up your challenge
and you're starting to use a lot of them
you you need to start using a lot of
domain knowledge to make those decisions
which again may go beyond just the
technical team so yeah so that is from
you know leveraging the the traditional
so now for global black black box
assessment feature importance a very
common one is permutation feature
importance where you know you basically
just permutate all of the input for one
specific feature and then you see how
much that influences the output on a
global level so this tells you like you
know on a global level with permutation
feature importance what is the
importance of each of the of your
features you know again you know this is
this is potentially biased in terms of
like you know you're using a very very
high level black box global approach and
that's why you need to take you know
specifically this feature importance
technique with a pinch salt and you need
to assess it depending on the use case
now on local black box model evaluation
metrics specifically on the metrics that
the The Alibi library leverages it
actually leverages this four key
approaches so it anchors counterfactuals
contrastive explanations and prototype
counterfactuals again another shout-out
to our data science team they just
published the paper this week on
improving the computation as you would
imagine is is very heavily
computationally to use black box
techniques so they released a paper that
approaches that using what they call
prototype guided by prototypes so I
don't recommend it to check it out if
you have time you know maybe tomorrow
after the hangover with that with the
anchors approach this is what we're
going to be diving into so anchors
themselves ask the question from this
inference instance that you send to the
model what other features that you know
make this prediction what it was what
are the features that effect that
prediction the most and in this case for
example with images what it would show
you is what are the pixels that affected
this prediction the most and you know in
essence this is quite intuitive because
it allows for potentially domain experts
to be able to make then higher-level
explanations of why why something may be
working and in this case what we're
going to be doing is we're actually
going to be importing alibi and we are
going to be creating an anchor tabular
anchor tabular explainer the way that
you will actually build your an assess
this black box model approach
is that with images it would replace the
pixels for a super pixel for text it
would replace the tokens for a neutral
feature which in that case would be an
ankh right which is like like like a
token that is neutral for tabular this
is an open research question so it's
basically what would be a neutral
feature right because if it's if it's
numeric if it just replaced for a zero
that may not be neutral that that may
actually mean something so in this case
that's why this is the only one that
this is the only explain that you
actually have to fit your your dataset
with because what it does it creates you
know first an understanding of what is
the minimum and maximum for each of your
numeric features and then you specify
well I want you to try the the quartiles
so ranges so it goes like try from you
know zero to 25% and if I have 2 50 50
75 0 to 100 right so you're just
basically you know just doing that
that's what it's going to be replacing
it with and assessing how it effects the
performance there so what we're going to
do now we can actually explain right so
for one of the for one of the the
predictions that we just sent you know
this one what does it have
so somebody of age 52 you know we are
using this anchor explainer to tell us
well what were the features that
influenced this to be what it what it
predicted right in this case you know it
influenced you know it being marital
status of separated and capital gain you
know less than zero point zero zero
right so that is basically what you are
able to get with this techniques you're
able to explain for a specific
prediction you know how to say you know
play out and we're gonna dive into a bit
more of this in the next few slides
because it's quite interesting now
before that I actually want to also
cover the other technique that we have
which is counterfactual explanations so
this basically is conceptually the
opposite it's not not really but like I
think for intuitive purposes like
conceptually it would be the other
perspective so whilst Ankur asked the
question of what are the features that
make this prediction what it was
counterfactuals asked the questions of
what would be the minimum
changes that I can do to this input to
make it not that prediction right and in
this case you know you have in this
question it predicted seven what are the
sort of changes that I can do to the
input there are the minimum possible to
make this not a seven and in this case
it is an optimization problem so it
tries to find you know what would be
that optimal answer and what is
interesting is that you actually cannot
only ask how to make it not a seven but
you can ask how can I make this seven a
nine right so then this would actually
you know show you how you can actually
trick your classifier in a way and this
is interesting because it intersects
with adversarial robustness techniques
you know in a way you're you're really
hacking and reverse engineering your
model but this is for explain ability
purposes and here again shout out to
other techniques you know as you can see
explain ability is quite popular so but
you know it's super interesting topic
that I really recommend to actually dive
into you know we have a bunch of
examples interpreter notice that you can
actually jump in and if there's
something that you'd like to add we've
had some really awesome suggestions so
please feel free to submit an issue all
right so now let's go towards the third
part which is production monitoring
right and this is a part that I'm quite
excited today because we're gonna be
diving much more than I have before in
the past and this is the question of
okay I build a model and perhaps I've
built an explainer now I want to put it
in production how do I deal with that
right well what are they what are the
approaches to actually tackle that you
know and in essence what we're gonna be
leveraging here is our open source
library called Selden which basically
does machine learning orchestration in
kubernetes so it allows you to take a
model and put it in communities and
expose the RESTful API or G RPC and
that's what we're going to be doing
we're gonna put our classifier in
kubernetes they're going to put our
explainer anchor Burnette these out here
I have a diagram that's easier so yeah
so we're gonna actually put a lone lone
classifier in production and what this
is going to do is you know we're able to
actually you know send lone
requests and get a response of whether
its approval rejected but also we're
gonna deploy our explainer which what is
going to be doing is going to be
listening for you to also send you know
a specific instance and then it's going
to take this instance interact with the
production model and reverse engineer
the explanation to that specific
prediction and then return the
explanation and I'll just pause there
because that's awesome right
it's basically an ability to introduce
machine learning infrastructure patterns
right so this this this we're gonna call
it the explainer pattern right and what
basically this would do is you're able
to actually deploy anything that
explains it right in this case is going
to be an anchor explainer but this can
be you know a counterfactual explainer
or just whatever it is right so the
point is it's a generic design pattern
that you know we're trying to really
dive into and understand better and for
us to do that the way that you know we
allow using this you know open source
framework is once you have your trained
model in this case we have a psychic
learn you know preprocessor I was
trained and you know the actual run
another model that was trained we're
going to be using dill to export the
model binaries so this is just basically
a pickle we're exposed to exporting the
binaries in into into a folder then we
are actually just creating a Python
wrapper that is going to load those
models from the folder and basically
just you know with this predict function
anything that gets passed as a input is
going to basically pass it through those
models and return the prediction what
we're gonna do now is we have a set of
scripts that take this wrap it and that
predict function is exposed to a restful
api so what that looks like is we define
the dependencies for that wrapper to
work scikit-learn dáil etc and then we
use our s2i script that basically takes
docker image so just to see how many
people here have used docker in the past
let's see a show of hands
oh wow production-ready room nice so
what we're doing here is basically
creating a docker container called lone
classifier version tag with version one
right so when we run this and I'm not
going to run it because I don't trust
the Internet and it's gonna take a
little bit of download all the
dependencies but yeah so what you
basically have is you know what do we
call it yeah so basically a long
classifier with you know 0.1 tag we have
a docker container again you know here
we have a coronated cluster that were
just gonna push that to right in other
words to push that into our communities
cluster we have to define a
configuration file and this
configuration file just says I want to
use that container as our model and you
can define a computational graph which
is based basically says like you can
have you know a pre process or post
process well in this case we just say it
only has one you know computational
graph component which is that long
classifier right and once we actually
define that we can actually use our
kubernetes CLI tool to just deploy that
specific one so in this case I already
have it deployed so okay step yeah so I
have it over there deployed well then
that when you actually run that command
it you know pushes that into your
kubernetes cluster you're able to
actually you know interact with it you
have the pods running you know get pods
you can see it here so that's our lone
classifier it's not explained you have a
lone classifier you know listening and
what that allows you to do is that
allows you to actually just interact
with it through the restful api so we
have here a you know instance of someone
852 and we're gonna use curl to send it
to our localhost port 80
you know specifying that we want the
lone classifier and then sending this as
and in the array so you can also send
like string and binary yeah we send it
and what we have here is the prediction
so this is the negative and positive
label
so we have a negative prediction so this
person Sloane got rejected but so yes so
now we have a explain it so a model in
production we can also use our Python
client to interact with it so again just
here you know if you can see it that's
the same thing but you can do it on
Python which is easier but the main
thing now it allows us to now build an
explainer but not just you know have
that explainer as as we had last time
but we can actually use the explainer to
talk to our production model right so we
have this predict remote function that
uses the set the client to interact and
send that data to our remote model and
when we run it it actually is able to
train the explainer using that remote
model right and here we can actually see
how you know the explainer you know
receives so this is the long classifier
the explainer is going to receive a
specific request you know this is the
request that we just sent now we'll be
able to see when we send a request the
explainer the explainer will talk to the
model so we'll see also a rice on
request per second and we actually
talked to it and yes so we can do now is
wrap that explainer so Dominic the
explainer we built expose it through a
wrapper that you know cause the predict
function build an image called
long classifier explainer which you
actually saw when I did the s step so
it's currently in production and when we
apply it it just runs it so we can
actually request explanations directly
to our explainer and you know here it
gives you the result that we have so
marital separates it but it also gives
you all of the things that it's sent so
now we can see that the explainer
received the request and you can see
that the explainer is actually talking
to the model in production so we now
have a deployed explainer with a
deployed model interacting between each
other and just wrap up to show some of
the more visual perspective because I
think with explanations it's always easy
when it's visual we actually you know
put together a UI that allows you to see
you know the your in this case your
income classifier as well as the
explainer so if the internet works we'll
be able to see it if not I actually have
them cached just in case in Tufts as you
can see it all the way here you know
always ready oh it's ready for the
internet yeah so here I'm seeing all the
predictions that have gone through into
the income classifier into the loan
classifier which is using the data set
and when I actually request an
explanation I mean here you're actually
seeing the exact same thing just shiny
and colorful and pretty right but you
know how much difference that that makes
I mean a lot for people that when you're
showing it but yes so here you're seeing
that prediction that you sent you can
see the same thing you know Mario states
of separates it you can see the gender
of a female in this case for this
prediction but ultimately the objective
of this is that now you can actually
leverage humans who would have known you
can actually not just deploy a data
science model and leave it there but you
can actually have domain experts
assessing those predictions and really
providing an augmentation of knowledge
when it comes to those things and
actually remember there's there's still
one one more one more small piece which
is this curve that we call the smile
curve and this smile curve what it does
it actually plots for your predictions
the number of the prop I pocketed by
probability you know the number of
correct and incorrect so it's called
smile curve because in a ideal world for
the rejected ones you would have you
know as close to you know you know zero
probability and then for the positive
ones you would have as close to you know
100 percent and in this case it's
interesting not only because you can
actually visualize your correct
incorrect predictions with the
probability but and also see the true
positives or negatives etc but also
because you can ask the question of it
was if I was to introduce
human-in-the-loop for review so instead
of the model just going through on a
specific range of like you know less
than 90 percent probability
you know how would my performance look
like in terms of accuracy precision
recall etc so this is the question of
like if I was to leverage humans how
would it perform right so with that said
we covered a lot of ground the slides
are available though and all the
examples you know you can access them if
you have other ideas you know please
feel free to to you know contribute and
you know we cover these three steps data
analysis model evaluation and production
monitoring yeah with that said if
there's time for questions I would love
to take them if not at the pub whenever
you guys ready yeah thank you very much
[Applause]